our first speaker
is actually
one of the leading experts on the vice
presidency if you have any questions
about vice this is the person you want
to ask
everyone please welcome
aaron so i'm here to talk about big data
at dhs
vast and varied i'm aaron mannis
i am a support contractor at the data
analytics technology center
at the department of homeland security
director directorate of science and
technology
the director of the data analytics
technology center is alex von savath
our contact information
is right here and i'll show show you my
contact information again
before
i talk about the data analytics work i
always like to ground things with the
discussion of what dhs
is
because the scope and missions of dhs
quite simply are huge
22 components 240 000 people
we all know about tsa
whenever i talk about working with
homeland security people mention
their experience with tsa but that's
only a tiny piece of it
even the tsa you see tsa is not the
transport is not the airplane
air traffic
security agency it is the transportation
security agency so what you see is only
a part of tsa tsa is also thinking about
how to protect surface transportation
all over the country
city buses
trains mass transit
and that is only one of the 22
components i just want to give a quick
sense dhs is responsible for securing
u.s borders while for facilitating
commerce i'm going to talk about that
a little bit more later we protect
cyberspace and critical infrastructure
that's
another way of saying we protect
everything
and what we've learned with the pandemic
is critical infrastructure isn't just
the electrical grid chemical plants it's
education it's supply chains
it really is everything it could be its
own cabinet department
a lot of people don't realize the second
largest federal law enforcement agent
law enforcement investigative agency
homeland security investigations
is part of dhs their remit
is to investigate any crime that crosses
u.s borders
that includes
national security export violations
that's a fancy way of saying
sending sensitive dual-use technology
say high-tech chips to somebody that
maybe shouldn't have it
like
a state that supports terrorism but hsi
also investigates human trafficking
child exploitation
money laundering
international gang activity
just a huge range of issues we oversee
lawful immigration we are the lead
agency for responding to natural
disasters
i'll talk about that a bit more in a few
moments
i really like to talk about the coast
guard because they sort of epitome
they're sort of in miniature epitomize
this huge array of missions we have
they are a military agency a law
enforcement agency a regulatory agency a
safety agency
so they are supposed to protect our
coasts but they also have an
environmental protection function they
also rescue voters at sea and guess what
they're also the lead agency for the
arctic
secret service is part of dhs we protect
the president
and finally there's the department of
homeland security and then there's the
homeland security enterprise the
homeland security enterprise means we
partner with state local tribal and
territorial agencies
first responders public health
emergency support
another point i have to make absolutely
is that we are founded on the bedrock of
treating individuals with dignity and
respect safeguarding civil rights civil
liberties and privacy protections this
is fundamental to our mission
every data science project i've been
involved with these issues have been
front and center
now you're a bunch of data scientists so
i'm sure a lot of you are already
starting to chunk some of these problems
and see them as big data science
problems for example protecting critical
infrastructure
you can see that as a big network
analysis problem right
critical infrastructure isn't just one
facility it's a web of interconnected
facilities
and we have to identify the critical
nodes and how best to secure them
whether from virtual or real world
threats
you can imagine
using big big data analytics to look at
cyber security data analyzing web
traffic to critical websites
the next speaker i know is going to talk
about a natural language pro
processing project
and that is huge for us because we
generate lots and lots of written
reports which have all kinds of insights
and the ability people can't read all of
these reports the ability to extract
meaning from them
consider the criminal investigation the
range of criminal investigations we have
all of the evidence collected
tools that can help us
find valuable intelligence
and then better protect the american
people here's the thing
so you can see a lot of our missions as
big data science problems
but we are constrained
the first thing i have to say is our
core function is anomaly detection
and i like to say anomaly detection is
not finding a needle in a haystack you
can brute force that if you have to
no
anomaly detection is finding a needle in
a field
of haystacks
sometimes we don't know what we're
looking for sometimes detecting the
signal from the noise can be extremely
difficult
finding anomalous activity we don't have
a baseline for what's normal activity
these are the challenges we face when
we're thinking about
illicit cargo
entering the united states when we're
thinking about countering violent
extremism
when we're thinking about
threat assessment
the other thing is a lot of our goals
are not subject to easy metrics
some goals you know some goals are
but
define
when i talk about disaster response what
is an effective disaster recovery how do
you measure that
the other thing is our stakeholders
want perfection we have a very high cost
for false positives we don't want to get
miss
we don't want false negatives we don't
want to miss a threat but we also
don't want to spend time
looking at something that isn't a threat
i mentioned dhs
is
this amalgam of 22 components each with
different cultures different
operating stand operating procedures
different missions different world views
different concerns
imagine linking
multiple legacy systems well that's us
except that the systems are made up of
people it's a real challenge and it the
multiple stakeholders requires complex
coordination
now i work at dhs science and technology
one of the 22 components we are the
research and development arm
of the homeland security enterprise
we do everything from we may we might
make critical gadgets sensors that
firefighters or police might carry on
their belt we might be developing
sensors
to detect wmd material and cargo
entering the united states
we identify best practices
and my particular corner the data
analytics technology center we're doing
big data research to support homeland
security missions and that can scope
from real nuts and bolts problem solving
to
big picture cutting edge research and
i'll talk about both of those
one of our big functions
our core function is to help dhs
components generate actionable insights
from the data they collect and one of
our core functions
is
we don't i should say we are within dhs
science and technology we're part of
something called hsarpa we're like darpa
for homeland security we're darpa
without the d the d stands for dollars
we don't have them
we have to be extremely strategic and
thoughtful
in the investments we make
one of the best things we can do
is look at the data analysis tools that
are already out there
analyze them determine if they're a
match for dhs components meets their
workflow and a big part of that though
is a lot of rarely do commercial
products
simply meet our unique needs so it's a
matter of really the back and forth
between
the dhs component the vendor making it
work for us
i should also say
that
in a lot of cases we need solutions that
scale we're talking about serving giant
government organizations
sometimes we can hack a
small scale solution and solve a pain
point but sometimes we're looking at
big picture items that can really serve
a whole agency
now i want to talk about a couple of
specific areas where we operate
customs and border protection
their mission is to facilitate trade and
travel collect duties on imports and
detect illegal entry of both criminals
and also smuggling
i've got that picture up there of the
san ysidro border crossing but if if i
could also show a picture of the port of
los angeles all of the cars all of the
people all of those cargo containers
that we're reading about entering the
united states the vast majority of it is
legitimate traffic and we want to
facilitate that
but
buried
is also
significant illicit cargo
this is an enormous complicated anomaly
detection problem
how and
we've worked on this where we have to
sit with the subject matter experts the
agents in the field
go back and forth identify the
signatures of what might be suspicious
and what we should investigate
further i want to mention this now there
are two particular lessons from our work
with cvp and other agencies one is
our subject matter experts know so much
but they're in
they're in the weeds they are
so engaged with the problem set
that getting them to abstract because
when you're doing data analytics you
can't get wrapped up in the details you
need to be able to abstract the problem
so that we can then do the analytics and
i find that's a huge barrier
it takes real patience the other thing
is
besides the fact that our adversaries
are adaptive things are changing all the
time is the data is messy when you think
about u.s import export data we're
talking about hundreds of millions of
entries
and there's all sorts of noise and mess
the same
business registering an import can be
spelled 20 50 100 different ways
i'm sure you all know this but the big
lesson is
your data hates you and wants to break
your system and it sure does with us
disaster assistance this is a critical
mission fema is part of dhs this is only
going to get worse
we've
with climate change we're seeing forest
fires we're seeing hurricanes and floods
and now the pandemic is a whole new type
of
disaster that we have to respond
disaster
assistance involves three bits there's
preparation that's what we call left of
the boom before the disaster what can be
done this is a great big data problem
can we look at information about a
community and identify the most
vulnerable points and render assistance
beforehand strengthen them
during response this is action-packed
stuff triaging information in real time
developing decision support systems
however
it tends to suck all the oxygen out of
the room we focus on how do we deploy
helicopters how do we identify the most
critical needs
in a crisis
that discussion sucks the oxygen out of
the room and prevents us from focusing
on
the preparation
and then afterwards recovery how do you
measure effective recovery there's
obvious metrics did people move back
did we rebuild houses but how do you
measure restoring a community
these
this is at the cutting edge of where
data science meets social science this
is the world where i live my phd is in
public policy not
nothing
mathy we've got we've got to get this
right because the problem's only going
to get worse
finally we have a very active program
called scilab we're doing this with the
cyber security and infrastructure
security agency it is a multi-cloud
collaborative environment for cyber
security and infrastructure
security research
long and short we've built a play space
a big ecosystem where across multiple
clouds
we can bring in data sets bring in tools
and really run them through the mill and
determine if they're going to work
for our
huge cyber security needs we are
directly responsible for the
cybersecurity of the u.s government
but we are working with
private industry
to affect to try and secure
the entire
u.s
internet
this is a critical realm
ultimately
we want to
we're exploring ways to extend this
beyond just
dhs s t and cisa and incorporate
the private sector because that's really
where a lot of the action is
these are a lot of our nuts and bolts
projects i wanted to talk quickly about
looking ahead because we do have
we have one foot in the practical
immediate we also have a foot
in for research looking farther ahead we
are heavily involved with these national
national science foundation ai
institutes there's the future edge
networks distributed intelligence
institute at ohio state there's the edge
computing
institute at duke there's the dynamic
systems at the university of washington
and of course intelligent agents for
next generation cyber security we're
really interested in edge computing
there's going to be a lot of sensors
but leveraging these complex diverse
streams of data in real time to support
disaster response
is a real challenge and that's one of
our big picture items ramnets and this
is
which is real-time analytics for
multi-latency multi-party metro scale
networks
as we move to smart cities we're going
to have all these varied sensors and
they're going to be breaking all the
time and we can't just shut down parts
of the city because some of the sensors
are down we need in real time being able
to assess information make decisions
and that's why we're supporting these ai
institutes so that we can start building
that capacity
let me end by saying you are most
welcome to engage with
dhs s t
we have a website
we're on all your social media
you can contact dhs s t
and you can also contact me
thanks for your time look forward to any
questions in the chat